okay we will start with number 314
before we move over to the virtual Press
Room
hi
what's the question
congratulations
for your Oscar win for the elephant
Whispers I'm Sunil from American Kahani
and we've of course spoken many occasion
so
um this has been a long journey for you
kartik
Raghu
AMU Bowman belly so what does this mean
win mean for you tonight
I thank you I first
want to say this is India's first ever
film to win
and it's two women
from a country of 1.4 billion
and this is India's first production to
win so very grateful for that thank you
Academy thank you Netflix and it means
the world to us and this is for Indian
cinema this is for my country
thank you
all right next up we have our virtual
Press Room women in entertainment and
then number 367 after our virtual Press
Room so women in entertainment please go
ahead
hi I hope you can hear me okay yes just
want to say congratulations and also
what kind of advice would you give to
women filmmakers
um
as you've had this journey
I want to share something here this is
actually what kartiki this is karthiki's
Debut film and also the first director
from India to win so more power
um I I do want to say that karthiki
started this journey five years ago and
the reason I am answering this is
because I'm sharing
um anecdote
um that she did not wait for anybody no
permissions it's filmmaking 101 she
picked up the camera shot started found
the story started shooting with the
subjects and made a beautiful Rail and
brought it to me as a producer and
that's also when Netflix came on board
but what I'm trying to say here is don't
wait for anybody just get started
there's nobody here to give you
permission there's you don't need a seat
on the table create your own table and
sit on it
and the other thing is is 100 passion I
didn't realize I was going to be six
years working on this documentary and
that's the only thing that made me get
up every single day and do it it was the
passion that I had for the the baby
elephants for the entire subject for
coexistence and literally putting this
message out to the entire world that's
the only thing that kept me going
all right number 367 and then we will
move back over to the virtual Press Room
hello Stephanie from showstv
congratulations I was going to ask the
previous question so I lost something
else
um how important was it for you to bring
this message out and also working with
different communities because you also
work with indigenous people and bring
their voice so yeah just the the vehicle
of filmmaking towards the messages you
want to share
working with working with indigenous
communities has been such a treat I
think they have so many messages for the
entire world for us to go back in time
and start learning about our planet and
how to coexist and Thrive it we've come
really far with technology but sometimes
we need to take a step back and
Indigenous people have that beautiful
ancient knowledge that's one of the
things and it's been a beautiful time
over the last five years learning about
ancient wisdom from a very old tribal
Community called the cartoon icons
they're just thousand seven hundred left
and I wanted to give indigenous people a
voice that's the reason why we we didn't
have an external rate or come in and do
it for the documentary we wanted to give
them a voice of Their Own
okay and our final question is from mea
worldwide on the virtual pretz room
hello uh guys uh congratulations on the
victory as the fellow Indian coming from
India congratulations the whole country
is proud of you guys right now thank you
and I just wanted to ask that you know
uh
you know documentaries are never talked
about in India they are always
suppressed and now that you guys have
won this award do you think that this
will pave the way for aspiring
documentary directors as well
absolutely I hope so and I think largely
for Indian Cinema I think we just got
started
I mean it's been a great year you know
so with all that reads with last year
rintu and uh with uh sushmith writing
with fire so Indian documentaries and of
course now with elephant investors
Sonic with all that breeze I think we
just got started it's it's a good run up
we share this with all the documentary
filmmakers The aspiring dreams of Indian
filmmakers and I'm sure I hope that this
empowers more filmmakers to go tell
their stories
wonderful thank you so much and
congratulations thank you
[Applause]